the next Oscar is for sound mixing it
recognizes the complex art of precisely
manipulating every single effect from
the faintest breath to the loudest
explosion here are the nominees
can I try that and the Oscar goes soon
Mad Max fury road Chris Jenkins fell off
and fed Ozma
this is the first Oscar and nomination
the third win and fifth nomination for
Chris Jenkins and the third win and
seventh nomination for Gregory block
thank you very much
first of all big shout out to the
Academy thank you for all your support
of our incredible creative craft to our
fellow nominees we can't say enough
we're so proud to be in your company and
we're so proud to represent tonight q
George Miller you're the heart and soul
of all this can't say enough about you
thank you thank you thank you for giving
us the opportunity to Warner Brothers to
all of our friends they're the people
that support us and most of all to our
families to our wives to Jean and to sue
to our family to James up on the cheap
seats thank you all very very much
thanks everybody thank to all
Australians and the millions